à
thierry c'est certain de joie de vivre
qu'il 3 mais vrai
exceptionnel la longévité
perfectionniste
apple chéri d'un coup j'ai 38 ans je
suis père de famille marié j'ai trois
enfants dont un bébé de 4 mois et
j'avais à boston aux états unis la
pression je joue un peu au squash
bonjour bienvenue chez les paroles un
coût non je suis du monde
ouais alors habite une maison en france
annonce habité terre au japon la
première mon aîné jean jouzel
quand tu te rappelles toi et ta voix là
et on a un petit troisième qui n'est pas
l'un qui est avec ma faim qui a 4 mois
gabriel on passe aux plus jeunes
d'accord les plus jeunes je suis un coup
daniel à chaque retour à la réunion
c'est de retrouver mes européen c'est
donc de me ressourcer saisir coin
retourner à la maison retourner chez mes
beaux parents
retrouver l'amour et l'attention de mes
parents et de mes proches toute façon
suivante encore reprises sollicité alors
ça change pas grand chose à partager
aussi d'ailleurs je crois que son épouse
kat est arrivé ici l ai dit bon sur
trois semaines alors je vois les photos
et tout ça sur facebook etc
les emails voilà un thierry on a fait la
fête des pères avec 40 personnes de ta
famille et tout bon j'y suis pas et je
m'en a pas mal de redorer notre ami on
se rend compte et là ça me permet de me
reconnecter tu vois de vraiment de me
retrouver chez moi depuis l'année 85
jusqu'à ces dernières années je pense en
compte 300 articles par dossier 2 oui et
en même temps c'est toute l'histoire de
la de la fédération française de squash
moi j'ai bien aimé puis bon quand on
part dans le journal vise une petite
gloire quand même alors on le ramasse et
puis et puis après je me suis fait un
devoir de rendre c'est vraiment tout ce
qui me tombait sous la main
voilà et puis un jour je pense que c'est
petit ça suffit ou ses petits enfants et
vient d'en bas papy qui a fait ça
je tombe
mais officiel van wel 23 officiel mais
le plus important c'est je donnerai les
international union à la silla c'est le
plus important
le premier beau titre cc du titre de
numéro un mondial c'était vraiment ça
c'était cette accession là c'était
vraiment mon premier objectif
et l'année d'après justement 2004 je me
suis dit bon mal à aller faut lever les
trophées maintenant le classement c'est
une chose c'est des points c'est une
moyenne
mais quand même aller au bout d'un
tournoi à prendre la photo avec le
trophée c'est pas mieux aller s go on va
voir ma femme et mon petit dernier
et puis on va aller au club de pascal ok
allez petit gabriel à paris par les
médias je ne comprend pas le message non
mais voilà c'est à l'avance c'est un
ambassadeur pour le squash à la réunion
et pour le sport aussi je pense qu'une
partie de la réunion après le bac
déraciné un peu être obligé de s'adapter
à la métropole
on a vécu à marseille aussi on s'est
refait un cercle et ensuite à boston ça
a été difficile oui bien sûr parce que
c'est pas du tout la même mentalité mais
encore une fois ça nous a ça nous a
permis de découvrir autre chose est de
nous renforcer encore plus c'est vrai
que j'avais envie en fin de carrière de
profiter un petit peu de demandes
notoriété pour pour vivre autre chose
j'ai une ouverture à l'université des
mighty on peut donc c'est assez
prestigieux c'est vraiment ce que je
recherchais et puis comme expérience
américaine pour ma famille j'ai eu un
peu de lumière gillot ouais tu me donne
de l'énergie la chine donne de l'énergie
j'ai aucun doute sur le fait qu' il aura
toujours des opportunités moyens de
rebondir avec sa personnalité pas
seulement dans le oui je pense qu'il a
une bonne étoile mais c'est pas qu'il
n'ya pas que ça c'est tout le travail de
fond qu'il a fait et puis son équilibre
en général et surtout sa personnalité
je pense que ça lui c'est vrai oui chez
pierre bien fait chier pour le squash et
à fléchir les jambes et seagate et j'en
vois là et romain
tu vois qu'un seul frère le voir une
fois par an et puis ensuite qu'une fois
tous les 2 3 ou 3 ans puisque maintenant
il est encore plus loin josé aux états
unis ça fait du bien de le voir elle
passait des moments surtout avec les
enfants qui grandissent et ça a été le
vraiment le moteur de cette discipline
tout simplement c'est d'abord une
histoire de coeur mais c'est surtout que
je crois que même s'il a quitté le
circuit
on dirait ce présent tout le temps parce
que quand on pense quoi je suis ici en
france à thierry quoi quelque part mon
club aussi c'est un petit peu un une
trace veut laisser dans le temps pascal
c'est quelqu'un d'extraordinaire parce
qu'il a non seulement il m'a poussé il
m'a aidé à progresser quand j'étais
petit quand il me battait tout ça il
m'avait vraiment inspiré et après une
fois que je suis passé devant lui il a
eu sept 7 cette intelligence et cet
amour qu'il a je pense envers moi de me
plutôt de me supporter de m'encourager
plutôt que d'avoir d'alimenter une
jalousie ou quelque chose comme ça donc
voila moi et moi je suis fier de lui
dans son parcours qui l'a eu en tant que
ma prof de psc ont plus de deux super
coach parce qu'il a vraiment former des
baux champion réunionnais donc bravo
dans un premier temps c'est
d'officialiser un petit peu les
relations qu'on a déjà avec saisie il
donc dans le cadre de compétitions des
changes où je vous provoque un peu
imaginent au chevet de bahia toi mais a
été discuté je ne sais pas qu'est ce que
vous voyez derrière cette hausse
je vois un exemple a su comme on a
échangé tout à déjà sur son double
parcours le parcours sportif le parcours
de reconversion l'arc aux professionnels
après et tout cela fait de la cohérence
et l harmonie ils soient mode de vie ce
qui est exceptionnel donc il faut le
faire savoir à chaque fois et qu'il est
venu il partage et partagent avec nous
des moments exceptionnels avec les
jeunes avec les espoirs mais aussi en
dehors
et donc là ils portent des projets avec
nous pour faire avancer le squash à la
réunion je suis vraiment fier de la
suite qui a pu avoir
quand je vois tous ces titres par équipe
ou en individuel
voilà maintenant il faudrait vraiment la
pousser un peu plus loin pour atteindre
aussi le niveau mondial donc là c'est
une autre étape et peut-être qu'il
faudrait que la moment donné je puisse
donner un petit coup de main pour
apporter ce supplément de competencia
bienvenue aux internationaux de squash
je pense que le sport de haut niveau à
la compétition déjà amène un degré de
maturité qui est quand même supérieur à
la normale et franchement est ce que
j'ai vécu en elle et en espace de 20 ans
a voyagé monde entier rencontré
énormément de gens à travers le monde
c'était quand même quelque chose
d'exceptionnel et de très très
enrichissant d'un point de vue personnel
ont conduit d'un épanouissement et la
vision que j'ai aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que c'est une vision très
optimiste de la vie et en général est
très positive les gens
vous voulez dire autre réunion pour quoi
faire
il commence vraiment à être reconnu en
tant que coach au niveau international
et ça c'est un bon tremplin pour lui une
belle reconnaissance et plein de
changements dans ma vie ces dernières
années aussi avec l'arrêt de ma carrière
mon déménagement etc terrain mais je
pense qu'on est toujours en mouvement
que d'une façon ou d'une autre je pense
que j'avais vrai quand même revenir
jouer un rôle ici et je ne sais pas
quand mais ça se fera sur i
dix ans après vingt ans après tu as
toujours l'impression qu'il joue pareil
quoi y'a toujours la même la même
explosivité dans la même générosité et
puis le web la même prestance physique
sur le court et j'espère vraiment qu'il
va
il va porter le squash encore plus loin
pour que ça devienne un sport entend
plus démocratique
il faut savoir dire non si des foires
passer un petit message trop gentille le
message c'est d'abord être bien dans sa
propre famille c'est avec mes enfants et
ma femme du moment qu'on se sent bien
vraiment à un endroit
je pense que ça c'est la clé
à
tant que frère tu ce que l'euro battre
un jour
on
sa foi qui intérieur quoi il extériorise
ça à travers le scotch
je suis collison profondément sais c'est
que ses enfants lui donner autant de
plaisir qui nous sommes amenés à nous à
bientôt
ciao bye